alright guys well hey make sure to
subscribe to screen junkies if you
haven't already of course you have
they're way more popular guys he's gonna
deep baritone
oh man you actually did that as my
impression most people when they
impersonate me go what's going on
reject nation Greg Alva here with epic
voice guy John Bailey who does the voice
of honest trailers that's the thing that
we always ask him to do when we're
hanging you know do you do never get
tired of being here with us today for a
very special honors trailers reaction
maybe you could kind of tell us what
this is Humphrey and I saw the robot
written by for Harry Potter which I did
voice I recorded that too and this is
the honest trailer for honest trailers
written by robots so just to clarify
this is an actual robot thing that it's
a real robot right now screen junkies is
doing this thing for a charity called
Women in Film yes and one of the perk
levels was an honest trailer based on
all the other homeless trailers here
this is the same robot that wrote the
Harry Potter book wrote this this
trailers was an honest trailers up
honest trailers written by a robot it's
for charity and it should be because
this is the most bizarre thing I think
I've ever recorded in nine years of
professionals and you haven't seen it
yet I have not seen it I mean I waited
to do this with you yes when I read this
I'm like how in the world or the editors
gonna make this video this is gonna be
fun so it's gonna be something but you
talk some more about it afterwards let's
let's check this out
because of your contributions to our
women in films here a winner right here
blocked an honest trailer ridden by the
AI who wrote that big Harry Potter
chapter it's like an honest trailer made
out of every other on its trailer
warning and it's gonna be weird
there we go from the technology studio
which created classics like the
irresponsible Englishman had a brave
little lawyer perky Brits who work on
small movies about all the strange
Hollywood choices and legendary director
Mike poachers it's the first treatment
that is literally a spy ancestors
superhero movie in a dystopian society
where everyone is always quoting house
everybody everybody lives but only one
Jonathan dares to ask who made that call
because Leipzig negotiations have guns
now professors invented new ideas about
move on and snake ons are always coming
out of the road this car who is feared
to give the most points worthy for
payments of all to watch while montage
who makes the audience think about their
weirdest cousin you know the one who's
read Jon Snow and polite European robots
this impressive dog in his terrible
souls that no one will ever forget
seriously why were there more minerals
in their magic can't be danced holograms
and a climax so epic I stopped worried
about the helicopters descending on your
home
you're both oh really - never want to
see in this movie the Yoda versus Dennis
the Menace fight not enjoy this horrible
about the problems of every lay movie
voice over by the crime here because
from Jesus you and the moment of a mind
that made a bad movie people yelling
exposition and whispering character
names this awesome car chase will be in
the movie and so will the scene where
two characters sit and read a magazine
is playing on every TV and strapped up
with this underwater twice worst look
like a masterpiece the same shots of
Wolverine sitting on computers over this
guy chasing a cool Nazis playing Pokemon
snap the little guy
[Music]
luckily shouldn't talk just has a very
sarcastic bug this smoking baby that
goes to me award-winning actor where did
all the puberty cops go that is gone
yeah okay okay I get it
jeez oh my gosh okay robot that they're
talking about there's this thing that
takes all the words from a thing you
dumped all the dialogue into it and then
it regenerates dr. strangers weird man
hard recording that to be honest I it
was actually really easy decisions I've
ever done because Spencer What's Eating
Spencer Gilbert grapes leader ex and
he'll throw some stuff and I'll add lo
some stuff we couldn't we had to stick
to the robot script and I was like this
is gonna be so hard to record and for
the most part I just like blew through
it but in my head the whole time I was
going through this I kept expecting to
fumble of my time to get stuck or such
weird words and I started realizing holy
crap the editors have to come up with
everything that I'm saying so slow clap
for you guys
that was so much like an imagination I
was on the phone I was like okay I don't
worry about it
is gonna come and confuse everybody one
last like inside bit we recorded this
last Tuesday the editors had one week
less than Wow
because I was watching her singing this
wasn't taking some time wasn't that
really good I was kind of concerned I
was like there's no way they're gonna be
able to make what I'm saying is it's not
positive I hope that's honest trailer
gets more popular I know it's like 14 on
trending right now but he should go way
up there well they did they did tell me
they said this is gonna basically gonna
be our honest trailers honest trailer
cuz everybody's like you need to make it
honest trailer for honest trailers and I
keep telling people because I don't make
them don't get no confused me with the
people who make though I'm just the boys
guy but I keep telling people like the
channel trailer was like our honest
trailer for yeah yeah that was like our
honest trailer for honest trailers this
is now well done John Bailey well great
great boys I gotta say I'm really
shocked that I did not but that didn't
take me hours during 9 years I've been
professional voice actor for nine years
that is the most bizarre thing I have
ever recorded out of thousands of things
that subscribe the real rejects click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons mean nothing John Bailey it
actually clicked the district's an epic
voice guy over here you have your own
YouTube channel all the social media
links are in there make sure to follow
this guy as soon as you can people which
is right now peace